let's go to tavish from india tavish
welcome what part of india are you from
um from town called pondicherry
which region is that it
it's in southern india it was colonized
by the french oh you should look into it
actually i should that sounds
interesting is is the cuisine more
french
uh nothing particular like that but
there are french cafes and stuff
um
what you might find interesting is that
there was like a tintin story that was
based over here as well a tin tin store
that's interesting
yeah all right well what's on your mind
today
um i want to ask you what your thoughts
are on immigration like because a lot of
right wingers accuse the left of being
open borders and
like just free-flowing immigration so do
you think that like there should be some
limit on immigration or do you think
that it should be an easy process
or what exactly oh yeah i mean listen
my position on this is not unique to the
united states countries have every right
and responsibility
to
set immigration policy
you they have every right and
responsibility to enforce the fact that
they have borders and to establish what
is the path to citizenship and how many
years or what what would be
disqualifying factors all of absolutely
of course uh that that should happen
what i where i think the problems are
include
what right-wingers want to do in terms
of using immigration to as some of them
want to do it allow in only white people
or mostly white people to have these
xenophobic and racist quota systems to
use immigration as a political tool
uh in order to try to shape the
electorate in a way that you believe is
advantageous to you uh the idea of
deporting
um individuals who were brought here as
kids by undocumented parents
uh through no fault of their own that
that's completely immoral and wrong to
do so they should get a path to
citizenship but of course yeah countries
can have immigration policy they can say
here's the amount of immigration that we
can have
and uh
of course i i
i am i have not actually even met anyone
who is like actually an open borders
person
yeah because like there are a few
leftists i've seen who are they want to
restrict immigration because they
believe that um you know it depresses
wages and things like that so i do
believe there is some truth to why they
want to restrict immigration but i see
that like there is a bit of xenophobia
which is that they want to preserve
america as an anglo-saxon white nation
is there any truth to that
is there any truth to which part
uh to like actually both like the that
the left doesn't want immigration
because of economic reasons and the
right is wanted because of cultural
reasons there's true there of course
there is truth to both of those things
you know on the wages the truth is
that the degree to which immigration
influences wages
is uh very very modest this has been
studied extensively and we have a
long-form piece about it on our youtube
channel and i also have there's a couple
of books on my reading list if you go to
davidpakman.com
economics i have a list of economics
books that i recommend and several of
them deal with this issue of immigration
and wages it has almost no impact and
much more of an impact is from
corporations that are willing to
illegally hire undocumented workers that
depresses wages much more than actual
legal immigrants coming in
right right
okay thank you for taking the question
my pleasure there's tavis from india i'm
going to have to research that french
part of india that's very very
interesting